hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the four horsemen my
little biscuits here with me and he's
gonna protect me from the water monster
isn't that right totally behind this
time sorry I won't do that you don't
have to wait you'll be right here by my
side unless I find you in the game
course metal band and you and go back to
him hahaha I'll be a great parent
someday that was unlighted but either
way this is getting really interesting
so my assumption is that the four
horsemen are digging their way into my
brain to make me all insane Oh bonkers
when the lamb opened the fourth seal I
heard the voice of the fourth living
creature say come I looked and there was
a pale horse
this riders name was death Hell followed
him they were given power over
one-fourth of the earth to kill people
using wars famines plagues and the wild
animals on earth well ok isn't that just
delightful and lovely that is cool
is that the portal area oh my god I'm
going to the portal area oh I'm gonna
play portal my favorite puzzle games now
what I don't know is I seem to have
missed a note for the second Horsemen of
the Apocalypse because I'm pretty sure
that there was another path that I could
have gone up before going down but
doesn't look like I need it so I guess
I'm just gonna go on my merry way a man
mr. scarce um here we are here we go I'm
just under the great big assumption that
I'm gonna be entering the sumbitch and
then going into the plane of hell and
pursuing these orbs in II to their
quarters oh yo all [ __ ] here we go
Wow that didn't work didn't maybe I'm
going through the back end maybe it only
allows front entry why is this glowing
no no reason just because I have a DD
and I decided to look at a mushroom
instead my very important task of
stopping the apocalypse this looks
important can I have that can I uh here
to enter the portal Tao shall approach
from the doorway and read out the
following transcript mortem pestilentia
Pelham farmers our God is calling me at
hansard bestow your grace upon me and I
shall serve thee for eternity
these must be the ritual rights that are
necessary to gain access to the
Horseman's realm okay so so so what
about that so I'll prose from the
doorway is that what you're saying this
doorway over here
where are they still gonna be on the
wrong side again oh the doorway ah
houses are uh babies plz bah vote oh no
solution
hello James our dog has called it me
that's it bestow your grace upon I shall
serve thee for excess water
he got with me all the days placing his
belongings on the table in front he
looked over at where she wants lay empty
was the room but not through his eyes
that doesn't make much sense chapter 2
the Horseman's realm which one oh it's
lovely
oh it's amazing what you've done with
the place
love the pile of bones from the last
adventure who wandered into here I'm
sure it was worth it is that a thing
right yeah okay cool Catherine I'm going
to help you I will stop them you let me
strain into a water moccasin last time
maybe I'm not supposed to be the one to
stop them okay so each of these
represent a different Horseman the
pestilence one the war one there's
something other one I don't know what
else hell I'm gonna do but I'm gonna
start with pestilence because it's gross
and I want to start with it anyway
because I want to weird everyone out
who's watching let's go baby
I'm well aware of
so I need to find a place to rest what
what a big baby
what a big whiny baby Oh big man needs
to go down and take a nap just yeah yeah
whatever he already took two naps and
now he just feels like he needs to rest
again after all this hard work the
doorway to death's quarter I imagine
that's a pretty fun one oh did I pick
the only one with an actual lever anyway
so I just the entrance whoa yeah I got
that okay so I must be down here that I
could go in here yes of course a nice
bed in a foreign realm this door isn't
where I need to accidently never in
order to destroy yours presumably it
will open once I attain all four I got
it okay so I get that and now I need to
find some place to rest there might have
been another pathway in the middle of
the to death and famine areas maybe
maybe maybe come up come on get me a
place to lay my head to rest apparently
not okay
so what am I supposed to do how am I
supposed to rest I can't rest I can't go
nowhere that's weird okay ow my legs
this place is astonishing as terrifying
as it is I am fascinated by everything
so if I worked out the realm is set up
into five sections where we are standing
now is the hub a room that links all the
other rooms together from here there are
four quarters each four horsemen I have
not yet delve into any of the quarters
as I fear for my life I'm going to stay
hidden for now and observe some time to
see if anyone is still in this realm
after several hours I will decide
whether to go deeper or return through
the portal is that even a possibility of
something that could happen
I'm not entirely sure but I don't know
where I could go to rest I need sleep
pretty please oh I can go through here
maybe ah come on
I'm gonna strangle you I wanna strangle
you with your own heads let me through
I demand entrance maybe ah here we go so
last year for fuel nice and safe
underneath the stairs the thing that was
hidden all along was me hello
did anybody stab me in the butt in my
sleep and no that's not a euphemism
literally I believe that the crazy but
stabber is actually one of these
horsemen all right going with my
original choice go into pestilence I'm a
big baby owner how many naps someone had
taken here
really don't think it was a good idea
he delving deeper into the abyss
something that horrified him he knew he
had nothing else to lose yeah because
the horsemen are currently killing
everybody in the world surprised they're
not meeting me here
oh that's green and goopy oh I like that
I like that I mean that's horrible I
still like that what are you offering
huh a laboratory set am I gonna create
some devious concoction what am I gonna
make what are you gonna have me like
salamander blood oh exactly what I
needed
Ives honest I'll write a potion to give
me immunity to that dangerous green
gasps you could find the salamander
blood on the shelf in this lab but
unfortunately I've used up all the other
ingredients that were up here there may
be more on the storeroom down the
corridor the key should be next to this
note the other three greens you need are
grave worm mucus teros net taro is venom
and old honey water once you have these
add them to the vials of this machine
and then turn the wheel slowly to ease
in the pressure the purple potion tastes
disgusting but it does prevent that gas
from a slow and painful death okay well
I wouldn't want the gas to die at all
how about we protect me and not worry
about the gas just yet so this reminds
me a little some something that I saw in
another story but I can't remember what
it was somewhere a green poisonous gas
did Dolph infect me into a month okay
that hurts my brain can I not go I don't
see any guess okay no no no no okay I'm
dead all right then well there's dumb
and stupid of me and I will not make the
same mistake twice
perhaps probably not okay so I have a
key where the hell was the story's then
oh it must have been one of the doors
over here okay I'm pardon me I'm very
dumb no not that one
there we go all right let's go into the
stores because storage has always been a
good thing in MU it is really
quiet guy just say that to the music
stopper is this intentional ah it's
really quiet really quiet yeah it's good
that's a good sign
okay ah
Tarot is venom terrorist venom terror
tirtir Oh Tito Tito who graver and mucus
oil oil
old honey water it is really quiet
why is quiet another light I didn't see
what I was what the hell was that is it
still there did it go away okay
I am almost l avoid a good thing I got
some more
holy crap it's quiet why do I hate the
quiet more than I hate the weird noises
ladies cuz the weird noises are some
kind of comfort to me
good googly moogly it is quiet something
is gonna jump out of me at any moment I
know that I know this they're using this
to build up tension I know this that's
what it's doing can't fool me is very
urgent
thank you
oh good now it picks up again Wow so
thingy
what am I supposed to do ah damn I don't
know where it is okay it's in there
that's okay I don't need a skier Oh
screwed Oh sir door on that nope there's
not what am i doing where am I going I
don't know what I'm doing I don't know
where I'm going I'm lost lost I'm lost
close that close that close that there
we go good I did it I did the thing wait
a minute no this way I didn't need to go
this is the way I went before Shh
I don't need to go this way because it
can't go this way oh boy
no look oil no Thank You mr. rat friend
you did save me some trouble blood of an
unfortunate reptile very cute very kooky
and cool is he still out there
how I guess that's a fact that I can't
open that anymore is it yes he's
literally standing on the other side of
that isn't he then I just bugged the
game to the point where I can't get
through this door again oh I did it was
a pull door oh it was a pull door how's
it it test on you guys see if you're
dumb and not me oh my god Oh Johnny back
damn Wow only this tiny box oh it's so
tiny
oh you're gonna help me out oh yeah I
still love you but oh he's here I didn't
think that you'd be here Oh what if I
simply say right was I right honey my
god
all right I'm doing him do him gone
dormant don't do him but do them in yeah
Oh God talk about stem pushed him but he
didn't do that
Hey
we need to get to my little biscuit
are you just going to watch me as I do
this you just like to watch don't you
weirdo here we go I'm doing this
apparently with him staring right at me
oh god I'll just take that
Oh
well it seems bad but I didn't get in it
I think I didn't get anything
Oh got it okay got it okay what's
happening right now
why Cannot oh I took die naptime you
watch over me as I sleep it's all about
totally fine we're still there good
I'm alive okay we're sad amongst him
through him this way ready to go I won't
leave without him
Darius we're coming tiny coming Tim back
he's on his way
we're on I liked him we're out of here
together forever till the Finneran
okay Oh Tim in the wrong way we went the
wrong way
god that's screaming in my ears just the
not-quite string screaming aah oh no Tim
I gotta go get Tim or sim Timmy Tim t'en
give me Tim Tim Tim Ritchie
okay all right there you are Tim sorry I
tripped over here for a second there but
I'm gonna be a-okay because I have you
here and that's good that good oh so it
didn't kill me right away just still
damage me well what was the point of
that I still risked it for you little
buddy I wouldn't be anywhere without you
I know you ain't mark that's why I'm
always here yay I gotta come up with a
cuter voice for you the voice I first
did yeah I know that's you that's you
through through I love you just the way
you are okay so what am i doing about
this hang on a second I'll get you in a
second Tim figure this out so some sort
of machine huh haha oh it's a
ventilation system
now I should be able to breathe without
dying a horrible painful death good
probably also summon some monsters my
way but I wouldn't never leave you
behind
when I do leave
I know the level transitions are not
kind to us Tim I will say where they
were okay so now the ventilation system
is currently active there's still this
lovely green glow around the area that
helps guide me on my way and there might
be a thick sorry Tim did I bonk your
head there okay good so long as I didn't
yay I got one yay Oh Tim no I'll have to
leave you behind soon but just stand
here and face the monster for me and
make sure that he never comes back
and if the horseman of pestilence comes
by maybe he just needs a friend
Tim you could be that friend you can be
the friend I never could Tim I don't
want to say goodbye but I Lalo how is
evidence spirit goodbye Tim I'll make
sure you're safe I'll try to get back
for you oh wait I gots a debug [ __ ]
right here
now I never have to leave him behind
ever again sorry for uh throwing you to
curb there a little bit sorry hey I have
an order i has an orb that can help me
stop the apocalypse don't know how but
that it dude alright so do I put them
here or do I need to take them to the
other side or do I just chuck them like
dodge balls through the portal and then
say goodbye to my friends and family
possibly pow well whatever I'm just
gonna keep going I need to remember not
to use my lantern so much considering
that it is a little more important as I
lay over her lifeless body everything I
never knew had forsaken me
are you talking about Catherine no what
happened what happened to your wife Oh
what the hell I can't be right
hello dude what the hell well what is
this supposed to be wait what am I doing
here what is this all about this doesn't
make any sense
what no okay oh it's not unlocked it's
like in probably phase you know another
realm or something oh oh I got a bad
feeling this is gonna be a mannequin
level oh you son of a [ __ ] don't say
that it's gonna be suit of armor
haunting me this trap was deadly it
seems a person before me tried to move
through the axis whilst they were still
active his leg lies severed on the floor
beside him I don't know how long he died
ago he died but he must have suffered
considerable pain fortunately I managed
to disengage the mechanism that makes
the axis swing now I move onwards into
the quarter light-footed cautious as
ever do not know what other trials may
lie ahead so who is our turn who is our
tour and why is he doing this and
obviously he failed considering the
horsemen are still on their way
rampaging through everything I know and
love and everyone I know is dying
currently very painful dead alright so
here we go I'm sure this is safe don't
mind me
yeah okey-dokey then yeah that looks
pretty cool I bet they're gonna become
activated when I get back
oh sorry I'll put mine out too it's
being total perpetual darkness oh
they're still rattling is that the drums
of war I hear thundering in my own chest
making my bosom rattle okay that guy's
dead
oh is it and say no whispering I'm all
right that guy that's the axe to the
butt stabber he's okay got some sailors
if that's important maybe we can take
him back home and do something about
that figure out what the hell thalers
are all about it who is that so I'm
assuming it's kind of important that I
picked these sailors up kind of getting
disconcerted ding that was I need 100
more coins well you're exactly in luck I
don't have that Gama to go get it what
are you give me a lunch money maybe no
sorry sorry is no
things will remind me Arthur you're
making me paranoid you put all these
mannequins around here I think that's
you oh I'm sorry oh I just serve some
what is that what is that what is that
what is that what is that turning on the
lights
turning the lights back on okay rather
have light I now live in here
huh okay die need 25 more tailors or the
other sailors I imagine they're in here
can't quite get to them I see you in
there
do I have anything no I can't grab them
really quickly yeah oh I did get him
yeah ah probably breaking the game right
now but I don't care I got my sailors
look up a sailors baby
oh good well congratulations for that I
hear something behind here something
going on here
excuse me Stefano's have you seen tiny
box tomb there's some behind there I
need to be able to get over there
what is with the big portcullis gates is
with that there's got to be some here
some um miss why did I light the candles
and then continue to use my lantern oh
wait coz I'm on it
Oh a key of course rusty key was
probably for this this was probably was
waiting for me I needed to do this there
we go and then there's all K I got it
where does this go
hello is anybody missing a handle you
can you want a handle in this wheel make
a baby maybe one that works properly oh
okay oh there we go there it is okay
that took me way longer than it should
have to find and ker nope not the other
way you almost got it there you go
that's kind of cool and creepy and I'm
afraid of what's gonna be waiting for me
on the other side hello dead body that
was the flies that I heard oh I have not
one I wanted a new hobby if I'm right
boy you are on a burger you get off
punch you right in the gabber oh yeah
you were nothing about of oil but you're
still nothing I'm out of oil cuz I
wasted trying to find the stupid uh-oh
oil I shouldn't have filled well then um
good I guess why is everything backwards
come on
would that do ah and you closed the
gates who him on the way back in the
water this is my favorite place to be do
water Moser splash wears glasses taking
a bath
sons of [ __ ] with your dad just one
look at ya psycho and a [ __ ]
stop it with that don't you know
Oh No Oh through turn three I'm not
ready for this okay so I looked like a
maybe a Catherine I've been here for
hours trying to figure out this trial so
far I have learned that you cannot go
back and stepping on in and correct
square will send you back to the
beginning it's infuriating I learned so
far that I can go forward right right
then left from here I'm a certain where
to go but it only seems solutions go
through the portal after following these
four squares I did however notice lever
on the Northeast quarter at a closed-off
chamber to the southwest corner I would
bet that this lever opens that chamber
okay so it's a puzzle huh it's a puzzle
huh all right so how did that pattern go
SC forward right right and left I can do
this forward right okay never mind
maybe forward that's the little first
one forward right right wait a minute no
no no no don't seem right all right what
about another path can't be that
infuriated ours really ours
maybe it's true maybe that's the only
way to go you hey we got an issue here
you got a problem to solve
yes I'll go through here what does that
do what huh well way that do forward
[ __ ] what the hell okay then that I can
ah okay all right then
so I think I know I think I know what
you want me to do I got you yeah now I
can go a new way so this is where the
portcullis is I just got to get to where
I need to go elsewhere what's over here
wait a minute no is it the beginning no
is where I came from this seems like it
yeah that's where I came from
I made a goof I've done goofed and it
ain't no good ah I see okay but I am on
the other side okay oh that's what it
did it poor to me over to the other side
oh oh you oh yeah did okay here this way
take off your head no I should have left
years on so that I know where a hell I
was that way you this way vacant and
then this way yes I did it I'm a genius
I'm a genius mama G I am a genius
I'm a genius I did it okay so now I just
need to do this again the way I did it
before and Dumbledore fool little double
loop with that bow oh [ __ ] this is the
other way whoopsies
did this wrong travel bull for Lulu hey
shadow people the ADO's d pas de cheval
a Louisville boo boo boo
there we go okay right here I passed it
how was that dumb banga banga banga
banga banga gimme gimme you if you're
reading this it means you have managed
to gain access to the prize chamber I
regret to inform you that I've salvaged
some supplies for myself as I was in
dire need of treating infected wounds
yeah though I would love some supplies
for whomever should find me in I also
leave you in the knowledge of another
secret hidden within this quarter I
found a note which says in a place where
the avian sits on torn fabric is where
you will find a button with the ground
shakes is where your opening lies you'll
find supplies within I have no time to
ponder about the riddle but if you
should attempt to solve it good luck
okay so for the Eagle lies with a torn
banner or whatever the hell that means
I don't understand [ __ ] alrighty I gotta
go the other way again yup but Aboudi
shadowy blue shadow dee doo dee wait a
minute no no no no ah damn it I gotta
get over there how do I get over there
wasn't I just over there couldn't have
been over there
this way I go this way this way to sway
to sway and not this way
yes this way okay god I did it so I
don't know if the torn banner was in
there for thousands some area ahead
either way I'm still moving
why were you spooked by that chair found
some more thalers that's good right why
do I need thalers you know what I might
have to wait until the next step so to
find out because I'm all out of time for
this one thank you all so much for
watching and once again there are more
ham knees or custom stories filled to
the brim with scares and delightful
things in the description below tiny box
Tim thank you all so much for watching
and as always we will see you in the
next video look at this tiny box
I'm gonna call you tiny box Tim you're
gonna come with me on an adventure tiny
box Oh
the bugs use